der bundestag hat heute die korona
notbremse beschlossen in zukunft gelten
also einheitliche regeln für ganz
deutschland abhängig vom incidents wert
schluss mit dem wirrwarr und den
alleingängen der länder mehr macht für
die bundesregierung und auch schärfere
maßnahmen zum beispiel eine
ausgangssperre von 22 bis 5 uhr ab einer
inzidenz von 100 das ruft die opposition
auf den plan die fdp will
verfassungsbeschwerde einlegen und auch
vor dem bundestag wurde heute gegen die
korona politik demonstriert bundes
notbremse wirksames mittel gegen die
dritte welle unser thema heute in der
phoenix runde
phoenix runde schönen guten abend ganz
herzlich willkommen aus berlin ich darf
meine gäste vorstellen erwin rüddel es
bei uns von der cdu und ist der
vorsitzende des gesundheitsausschusses
des bundestages zu dem abend und ich
begrüße professor dr andré ullmann von
der fdp im bundestag auch und mitglied
des gesundheitsausschusses selbst ist er
facharzt für innere medizin und
infektiologe zugeschaltet ist uns
professor alina buchs ist die
vorsitzende des ethikrates und ich
begrüße michael brücker erst
chefredakteur des medienunternehmens the
pioneer von professor fuchs wenn man
sagt man muss die menschen mitnehmen
hilft dieses gesetz weil es jetzt
endlich einheitliche regelungen gibt
weil das war ja gerade ein problem das
viele leute sagen ich weiß gar nicht
mehr was jetzt gilt ich muss jedes mal
nachschauen
wenn ich von weiß was ich berlin nach
brandenburg fahren dann gibt es wieder
was anderes ist es etwas wo sie sagen
das macht das ist ein gutes zeichen um
die gesellschaft mitzunehmen in diesem
kampf gegen die pandemie also es ist
jedenfalls so dass es ganz gute
befragungs studien gibt die gezeigt
haben und zwar über monate dass dieses
ausfransen nach den ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen also das eine wurde
geschlossen und dann kletterte das so in
unterschiedliche richtung dass das von
sehr vielen menschen als sehr
frustrierend empfunden wurde am so dass
ich davon ausgehe dass einheitliche
regeln die dann einfach überall gelten
aber eben je nach situation angewendet
werden dass die aber nachvollziehbar
sind dass sie auch verbindlich gelten
dass das schon etwas ist was viele
bürgerinnen und bürger in biologischer
finden
als diese doch sehr unterschiedlichen
zum teil dann auch widersprüchlich
angewandten regeln die wir in den
letzten monaten hatten ich glaube
einfach für viele kommt dass jetzt auch
zu spät
wenn man sich da die befragung anschaut
ist das doch sehr erstaunlich wie hoch
die zahl derer inzwischen ist über 40
prozent die sagen es muss stärkere
maßnahmen geben das hatten wir so
eigentlich nur in diesen letzten
mehreren wochen dass das tatsächlich so
ein klares bedürfnis gab
und vielleicht wird das dann zumindest
einigen in der hinsicht entgegen kommt
dass das als konsequenter wahrgenommen
wird
es kommt spät michael brücker es kommt
später als als die kanzlerin gewollt
hätte die ja schon im oktober gesagt hat
wir müssen viel schärferen lockdown
haben dann gab es jetzt wirklich diesen
tiefpunkt mit der oster ruhe wo sie sich
danach entschuldigt hat nach dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
haben sie den eindruck dass jetzt angela
merkel mit diesem gesetz wieder das heft
des handelns in der hand hat ja
einerseits hat sie das natürlich aber es
kommt tatsächlich zu spät wir reden hier
über anfang märz als die
ministerpräsidenten runde eigentlich die
maßnahmen die jetzt in gesetzesform
gegossen worden sind beschlossen hat
sich nur nicht daran gehalten hat oder
kein einheitliches bild abgegeben hat
nehmen wir mal an wir hätten die damals
sehr schnell strikt vier wochen und dann
vielleicht aber auch verhältnismäßig
klar einheitlich umgesetzt dann würden
wir heute mitte april ganz woanders sein
und vielleicht sogar in der
außengastronomie sitzen
jedenfalls kommt es zu spät aber dass
das gar nicht mehr der hauptpunkt ist
der hauptpunkt ist dass es nicht
verhältnismäßig ist das nicht
transparent und nicht nachvollziehbar
ist
das ist doch das große problem einer
ausgangssperre die oder eine ausgangs
beschränkung wie es dann verniedlichen
bezeichnet werden soll
die hilft natürlich nicht wirklich wenn
doch gerne draußen das infektionsrisiko
so niedrig ist wie nun die forscher aus
anderen wissenschaftlichen gebieten
jenseits der virologie sagen insofern
hat man sich aus meiner sicht auf die
falschen felder konzentriert während ich
morgens im vollbesetzten bus oder in der
bahn fahren darf ich abends nicht mit
meinen besten freund oder mit meiner
ehefrau und einen spaziergang machen da
sind aus meiner sicht die will die
willkürlichkeit und auch die
widersprüche passiert und das ist das
was das vertrauen kostet und jetzt kommt
es sehr spät vielleicht sogar zu spät
und es ist immer noch nicht
nachvollziehbar insofern ist es keine
sternstunde der deutschen pandemie die
politik die wir da heute erleben aber
sie ist es gibt eine einheitlichkeit
aber eben bleiben wir mal bei der
ausgangssperre die ich ja tatsächlich
sehr umstritten herr rödl warum halten
sie denn für sinnvoll warum haben sie
dem denn zugestimmt weil es ist ja
tatsächlich so dass draußen weniger
infektionen ist jetzt mit das wetter
besser jetzt könnte man doch auch abends
länger draußen sein was es da das
problem
also ich denke es gibt viele
möglichkeiten das also ob im
einzelhandel im sport individuelle
lösungen gefunden werden
über testen und abstandsregeln damit
dass man solche dinge öffnen könnte aber
insgesamt haben wir das problem dass wir
zu viele kontakte untereinander haben
das fängt in der schule an und geht über
in letztendlich bis hin zur familie und
in anderen alltagssituationen
das heißt wir müssen in eine situation
kommen dass wir kontakte insgesamt
reduzieren damit das virus nicht mehr
diese möglichkeiten hat sich
auszubreiten und deshalb haben wir jetzt
diese ausgangssperre von 22 uhr bis 5
uhr morgens die meisten heute
wahrscheinlich zu hause sind und
schlafen hier ja aber aber es gibt
erfahrungswerte aus anderen ländern
die also sagen dass man etwa ein drittel
der kontakte reduziert kann also ich
komme aus rheinland pfalz und lebe in
einem landkreis der also mindestens
schon seit vier wochen ausgangssperre
hat abends 21 uhr
und wir haben auch eine landesregierung
in der die fdp vertreten ist und ich
wüsste nicht dass der stellvertretende
ministerpräsident der auch
generalsekretär der fdp hier in berlin
ist im verfassungslage eingereicht hätte
weil sie kriegen alle zahlen ich runter
in ihrem landkreis
wir haben sie leicht runter bekommen
aber ich denke also zumindest sind sie
in einer zeit wo in anderen bereichen
die zahlen gestiegen sind bei uns nicht
in dieser dynamik gestiegen trotzdem ist
ja die frage der verhältnismäßigkeit
kritisiert und was die afg auch ganz
klar kritisiert hermann warum ist das
nicht verhältnismäßig wir haben jetzt
mehr begrabt von beispiel entsprechend
aus meiner heimatstadt würzburg habe ich
die heute die zahlen erfahren da haben
wir im augenblick eine ausgangssperre
und wir hatten vor einigen tagen noch
eine zahl von 190 jetzt bei knapp 150
also auch es geht auch ohne
ausgangssperren
und man muss auch die
verhältnismäßigkeit sehen nach 22 uhr
bis 5 uhr morgens passieren kaum
infektions übertragen diese wahrheit
muss man auch ins auge schauen und das
ist eine tatsache die andere frage ist
tatsächlich ob diese grenze 100 pro 100
infizierte pro 100000 pro woche auch
eine richtige zahl ist wenn man nicht
einen dynamischen faktor mit einbaut in
diesen diese zahl hinein und zu sehen
wie ist eigentlich diese dynamik der
pandemie vor ort und hinzu kommt jetzt
auch zu der mehr menschen haben die eine
vollständige impfung haben ist es noch
verhältnismässig dass diese menschen die
wahrscheinlich nach robert koch institut
von professor wieder ja auch schriftlich
so fixiert wahrscheinlich kaum noch ein
risiko darstellen andere leute
anzustecken ist es noch verhältnismässig
diese menschen den grundrechten
vorzuenthalten dass die draußen
spazieren gehen können
das sind unsere kritik in die wir
ausgelöst haben und noch einmal die
kritik an die fdp nach rheinland pfalz
das ist jetzt ziemlich unfair
das gesetz ist heute erst verabschiedet
wollen im bundestag rödl und wir haben
jetzt erst mal als bundestagsfraktion
einzeln da anträge aufgestellt dass wir
jetzt verfassungsklage einreichen wollen
und ich wäre nicht überrascht wenn herr
bisschen sich dazugesellen würde
trotzdem ich dann noch mal die frage ist
ja ein sehr starker grundrechts sehr
starke einschränkung frau box kann man
das kann man das verantworten oder ist
es tatsächlich ein einfach ein zu großer
eingriff in die individuelle freiheit
wenn wir die regierung sagt dass ich um
22 uhr zu hause sein muss also das
gehört weiß ich von meinen
verfassungsrechtlichen kollegen dass sie
das schon als eine sehr starke
beschränkung der individuellen
freiheitsrechte einschätzen
ich glaube da ist ja noch nachgebessert
worden also da sind eben das joggen und
das spazierengehen herausgenommen wurden
bis mitternacht also gerade die dinge
bei denen man wirklich weiß dass da
keine ansteckung stattfinden bleiben
weiter möglich und wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe ist sinn und zweck der
übung ja auch nicht die kontakte draußen
zu reduzieren sondern dafür zu sorgen
nicht nächtlich kontakt drinnen
stattfindet also dass keine treffen
stattfinden
denn da gibt es hinweise dass das im
moment tatsächlich passiert und das
sozusagen dann ganz unkontrolliert den
innenräumen zusammenkünfte passieren und
das hat man in anderen ländern
jedenfalls teilweise da gibt es
unterschiedliche erfahrungen schon mit
solchen ausgangs beschränkungen werden
können aber ich muss ihnen sagen das ist
ganz zu recht auch eine umstrittene
maßnahme ich glaube was wichtig ist zu
unterstreichen ist dass das ganze jahr
auf zeit ist das ist ganz erheblich bei
1 wenn man so etwas diskutiert und wenn
so etwas dann auch eingeführt würde dass
das eben eine begrenzte zeitliche dauer
hat bis ende juni absolut maximal und
natürlich auch immer wenn eben bestimmte
instanzen erreicht sind für eine
bestimmte zeit ja wobei das immer so
eine sache ist wir hätten letztes jahr
auch nicht gedacht dass wir noch sehr so
lange mit der pandemie zugang ist wenn
man sagt auf zeit das ist immer schwer
zu glauben jetzt ist allerdings ist es
tatsächlich so dass natürlich in unseren
nachbarländern in frankreich in spanien
auch in den niederlanden gilt seit
januar die niederlande ausgangssperre ab
1 und 20 uhr jetzt 22 uhr da wird das
alles so gemacht herr brücker sind wir
dazu etwas wo man sagt da das mögen wir
in deutschland einfach gar nicht dass es
jemand sagt sind wieder anders als
unsere nachbarn
nein glaube ich gar nicht ich bin ich
finde wir müssen genau anschauen in die
daten und in die zahlen und das
differenziert betrachten das ist teil
eines maßnahmen mix es in den anderen
europäischen ländern aber es gibt eben
die kausalität eigentlich nicht die
wissenschaftliche studie muss man mir
zeigen wo eindeutig klargestellt wird
dass dieser massive eingriff in die
grundrechte gerechtfertigt ist und wenn
ich frau professor brüx geradezu höhere
ein hoffnungswert weil eventuell private
partys wie übrigens auch so jetzt
passieren könnten wenn sich studenten
dann jetzt in der wohnung treffen und
ein halt eben dort eine nacht party
machen um 5 wurde das wieder rausgehen
dann habe ich natürlich privaten treffen
auch nicht wirklich untersagt
ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher ob es
funktioniert und die kausalität gibt es
nicht keine wissenschaftliche studie
belegt dass wirklich es ist jemand teil
eines pandemie bekämpfung smeekes und
dafür ist wir diese grundrechtseingriff
einfach zu scharf und würden auch nicht
heerscharen von verfassungsrechtlern
dieses urteil fällen das ist ja nicht
nur die fdp sondern da gibt es eben doch
immer juristen die das so sehen insofern
glaube ich andere maßnahmen schnellere
härtere während wirksamer als diese auf
die sich natürlich zu recht jetzt auch
der frust und die kritik dann
eingeschossen hat also ich glaube uns
fehlt die klare wissenschaftliche basis
für diese maßnahmen und deswegen ist sie
aus meiner sicht nicht gerechtfertigt
eine frau bog sie ja vorhin gesagt am
anfang war das jetzt etwas weniger oder
das alte sind teil der mensch also 40
prozent sogar sagen wir müssten das
eigentlich alles härter machen und noch
schärfere maßnahmen haben haben sie das
gefühl dass die die ministerpräsidenten
die bundesregierung noch ein gutes
gespür haben für die bürgerinnen und
bürger wie sie im moment das empfinden
die pandemie politik also ich muss erst
noch mal bei meinem vorredner einfach
recht geben
beim härtere und effektivere maßnahmen
wären dem vorzuziehen also das möchte
ich auch nochmal einmal unterstreichen
ich hatte nur mich konkret auf die frage
nach der ausgangssperre bezogen wie die
sozusagen einzuordnen ist und dieses
eine element hat mir noch gefehlt aber
da bin ich wirklich ganz dabei ich
glaube auch dass das tatsächlich was ist
was relativ viele bürger wollen würden
man sieht in ganz vielen befragungs
studien dass die die akzeptanz der
maßnahmen abnimmt dass das vertrauen in
die korona politik abnimmt da ist so
seit dem winter hat ist da wichtig was
gekippt und wir sehen auch dass diese
solidarische motivation die wir im
ersten lockdown gesehen habe
dass die sehr sehr gelitten hat das ist
etwas was wir vom ethikrat tatsächlich
ganz früh schon mal gesagt haben dieses
potenzial sich solche dinge an zu tun um
es einmal so zu formulieren damit muss
man sehr behutsam umgehen und da ist
einfach ganz klar den bürgerinnen und
bürgern wurde unglaublich viel zugemutet
als erschöpfung da da ist gereiztheit da
und diese solidarische potenzial das ist
etwas erschöpft das wird sich wieder
aufbauen ich bin da zuversichtlich aber
das muss man dann proaktiv in der
zukunft angehen
im moment wohl die leute einfach dass
das vorbei ist
und da sind diese maßnahmen sicherlich
kein lichtblick wenn überhaupt dann ist
es die hoffnung darauf dass die
impfstrategie jetzt ordentlich gas gibt
und das ist schneller gehen wird und
dass man dann tatsächlich schnell auch
einfach diese art von maßnahmen nicht
mehr braucht herr riedel was ist er
empfindet wenn sie im wahlkreis auch
unterwegs sind
empfinden sie das auch so die menschen
sind erschöpft und worauf setzen die
wenn sie jetzt nach hause fahren und
sagen hier wir haben jetzt hier ein
tolles gesetz beschlossen
glauben sie das ist das worauf die
menschen warten also die menschen warten
darauf dass endlich wieder mehr
freiheiten mehr normalität kommt und
akzeptieren nach meiner wahrnehmung dass
wir jetzt noch mal zwei drei wochen um
zusammenreißen damit also sein nehmen
sie denn die die ideen oder die das
wissen dass es nur zwei drei wochen sind
also die erfahrung zeigt zumindest dass
die chance besteht wenn wir jetzt
konsequent sind dass das also ein
überschaubarer zeitraum ist in ober
konsequent sein müssen wenn ich bin ich
insgesamt sehe wie andere länder auch
die immer als beispiel genommen werden
die auch beim impfen etwas schneller
gewesen sind bis jetzt als wir sie haben
wesentlich härtere maßnahmen wesentlich
länger gehabt mit wesentlich weniger
erfolg also wir sind relativ gut aus
also nicht zufriedenstellend ich weiß
dass die menschen genervt sind die
wollen endlich diese freiheiten aber im
verhältnis zu anderen ländern ist es bei
uns insgesamt gut
laufen gut gemanagt worden es ist das
rote s ich will das nicht beschönigen
aber wenn ich das jetzt betrachte ich
muss immer sehen wie wird das im moment
hier bei uns wahrgenommen
oder wie ist das im vergleich zu dem was
in anderen ländern ist und da glaube ich
sind wir relativ gut durchgekommen im
verhältnis zu anderen ländern müssen
jetzt sehen dass wir etwas zulegen
und ich habe ich nehme auch hoffnung
daraus ich habe eben gesagt wir haben in
drei wochen so viele menschen geimpft
wie vorher in drei monaten
das werden wir im mai nochmal
verdoppelten das heißt also in einer
woche anderthalb wochen werden wir so
viele menschen impfen wie im ersten
quartal insgesamt wird wir werden am
ende ende mai werde sich ins amt gehievt
haben ende ende juni 60 prozent und
hätten damit sieht man an der
herdenimmunität also man muss ja einfach
den lichtblick sehen durch impfen
das läuft über über ärzte im juni über
betriebsärzte das heißt die menschen
kommen relativ schnell jetzt zu ihrem
impfschutz und deshalb müssen wir jetzt
konsequent sein und ich glaube dass wir
mit zwei drei wochen hinkommen wenn wir
konsequent sind und dann können wir
steigen
ich bin vorsichtig in verbindung mit der
impfstrategie da kommt ja zwei wellen
zusammen ok dass wir das hinbekommen
herr ullmann sind sie ähnlich zuversicht
oder wir hören sie wollen kurz
widersprechen habe ich den eindruck ich
habe das gefühl dass wir hier in eine
dauerwelle letztendlich unterwegs sind
wir hatten eine dauer lockdown light
eine
ein wellenbrecher lockdown und dann
hatten wir jetzt den brücken lockdown
und den jetzt die notbremse immer andere
als effektive und nimmer die vertröstung
zwei drei vier wochen und dann haben es
geschafft wir reißen zusammen zu
weihnachten reißen wir uns zusammen zu
ostern das glauben die leute nicht mehr
weil die ergebnisse kommen nicht die
akzeptanz geht verloren da bin ich ganz
bei professor wirkt das wir akzeptanz
brauchen dh das muss perspektive eine
echte perspektive kommen die impfung
sind eine perspektive ist keine frage
aber die frustration ist additiv wenn
man sieht dass andere länder zum teil
schneller geimpft haben als deutschland
oder aus europa oder wir innerhalb der
unlock dauern ja und wir auch innerhalb
von europa auch nicht gerade vorne dabei
sind mit den im frühjahr hatten das muss
man auch das gehört zur ehrlichkeit
genauso dazu ich bin optimistisch dass
wir mit der impfung das hinbekommen da
dieser meinung teile ich absolut aber
die die frage stellt sich für mich noch
einmal ganz explizit wie können wir die
menschen mitnehmen können wir die
menschen mitnehmen in dem wir sagen wir
greifen jetzt noch härter ein und ihr
dadurch jetzt mit eurem grundrechten
weiterhin eingeschränkt und auch
manchmal auch die fehlende innere logik
bei den maßnahmen das haben wir häufig
genug erlebt das habe ich auch als
kommunalpolitiker häufig genug erlebt wo
die menschen zu mir gekommen sind was
macht der da in berlin und sagen das
sind wenn ich das sind die anderen aber
letztendlich das ist die frustration die
sich da breit macht und wir verlieren es
ist reicht nicht aus wenn wir nur eine
mehrheit bereit ist daran teilzunehmen
wir müssen alle mitnehmen das ist
nämlich wichtig nur so kann man eine
pandemie auch beseitigen
herr brücke sie wollten auch gerne
widersprechen ja ich finde man bei allem
respekt lieberherr rödl
man darf natürlich jetzt nicht einen
koalitionspolitiker durchgehen lassen
dass er jetzt die impfkampagne auch noch
zum erfolg um definiert und sagt im mai
im juli da sind wird auch durch nahm was
doch geschafft wir haben ja jede woche
kostet die volkswirtschaft drei bis fünf
milliarden euro sowie den locker und den
wir gerade haben selbst einen lock down
light oder nennen wie sie wollen
insofern zählten eben gerade weil der
impfkampagne natürlich jede woche jeder
monat jeder tag insofern dass wir jetzt
im mai und juni endlich soweit sind
wunderbar aber was die leute doch stört
und damit muss ich ihn einfach
widersprechen ist ja nicht dass sie dass
die pandemie noch nicht vollständig
bekämpfte sondern wie
sie bekämpft wurde die willkürlichkeit
die widersprüche dass der gesunde
menschenverstand abends an beim
gartenzaun einfach mir keine argumente
mehr liefert für diese politik schauen
sie sich den incidents für 165 jetzt an
da wird das arithmetische mittel
genommen eines beliebigen montags und
werden werden die inzidenz einmal in
deutschland weit sich angeschaut und
sagte ok nehmen wir die mitte für die
zentrale frage ob wechsel unterricht
oder distanz unterricht und diese diese
begründungspflicht die politik geben hat
mal so einschränkenden maßnahmen das ist
doch das problem und nicht dass die
menschen sagen ja ich will endlich raus
aus der pandemie natürlich wir werden
wir werden aber viel ruhiger in diesem
land viel entspannter bin wenn die
pandemie politik nachvollziehbar wäre
wenn sie transparent wäre wenn sie
verständlich wäre das ist doch das
zentrale problem
und dass die impfung verbaselt wurden
das ist mir nun alle und das ist dann im
juni endlich soweit ist vielleicht mit
der herden impfung oder im juli das
freut uns sehr sagt uns luft massiv leid
gekostet und milliarden frau brooke wie
wichtig ist diese transparenz und wenn
wir gerade auch auf diese inzidenz werte
schauen also 100 wenn es mehr als 100
sind dann gilt die ausgangssperre in den
landkreisen
wobei ja auch noch meine frage ist wenn
die in dem ein landkreis gilt und in dem
anderen nicht wie macht man das denn
wenn man von einem zum anderen geht dann
bei 150 darf man glaube ich einkaufen
mit negativem test bei 165 das gilt
wieder für die schulen müssen die in den
distanz unterricht ist das was menschen
noch verstehen und oder müsste es andere
kriterien geben für die maßnahmen
also das sind zwei verschiedene fragen
wenn ich fange mal mit der ersten an
ich glaube man sollte die leute nicht
unterschätzen
wir sind jetzt seit über einem jahr in
dieser pandemie zusammen und ich glaube
die menschen sind schon in der lage
durchaus auch komplizierte regeln regeln
zu verstehen aber ich muss ja brücker
wirklich enthusiastisch recht geben mit
blick auf erklären auf
nachvollziehbarkeit und auf transparenz
es gibt wirklich wirklich viel
sozialwissenschaftliche forschung
inzwischen die ganz klar zeigt
wenn menschen verstehen warum sie etwas
machen wenn man das begreifen kann warum
etwas gemacht wird weil dieses oder
jenes ziel damit angestrebt wird
und wenn man auch fühlt dass das
funktionieren kann dann wird sich daran
auch gehalten das ist das problem bei
der ausgangssperre das hatten wir ja
eben schon gesprochen weil da versteht
man das eben nur so halb deswegen ist
das ein echtes tatsächlich ein echtes
problem ohne echte herausforderung
also das ist das ein und ich glaube das
ist wirklich verpasst worden
dieses immer wieder erklären eine gute
klare kommunikation zum teil gibt es das
jenaer ist auch regional sehr
unterschiedlich aber zum teil eben nicht
und da sind sicherlich einfach dinge
versandt worden
wenn ich eine frage im moment noch
einmal eine kurze nachfrage
wer hat das ihrer meinung nach versäumt
hat dass die bundeskanzlerin versäumt
haben es die ministerpräsidenten
versäumt also vielleicht machen es noch
ein bisschen konkreter wer das
eigentlich versäumt hat und da hätte man
sich jemanden hätte man sich so jemanden
gewöhnt wo man weiß der führt mich jetzt
hier durch diese pandemie also ich sage
etwas unpopuläres ich fand eigentlich
dass die beispielsweise die beschlüsse
die beschlussvorlage von den
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen da war
immer durchaus einiges an erklärung drin
aber das liest natürlich kein mensch und
was einfach gefehlt hat ist eine
übersetzung nicht nur dann in ein zwei
pressekonferenzen auch da wurde noch
recht viel erklärt und zum teil fand ich
auch verständlich sondern dass es dann
in die breite geht dass man eine breite
gut designte sein public health kampagne
fährt die auch auf aktuellster forschung
beruht dies ergibt und einfach gut
kommuniziert für unterschiedliche
gruppen in unterschiedlicher art und
weise
in unterschiedlichen sprachen über
unterschiedliche kanäle unterschiedliche
akteure einbindet ich bin weiß gott
keine kommunikationsspezialisten aber da
weiß ich dass es da ganz viele sehr gute
konzepte gibt es gibt auch einfach
länder die das anders und besser gemacht
haben und ich glaube zu unterschätzen
wie wichtig es ist transparent und
nachvollziehbar diese komplizierten aber
eben auch wichtigen regeln sozusagen in
die bevölkerung zu bringen das war
wirklich ein wichtiger fehler
okay wir kommen gleich noch mal zurück
auf die kriterien aber ich würde ganz
gerne mal mit herrn rödl nochmal drüber
sprechen also wie könnte man was wenn
man jetzt weiß das ist nicht so gut
gelaufen die kommunikation ist nicht gut
gelaufen
wie kann man das jetzt noch ändern wird
sich das jetzt ändern wenn man sagt
jetzt hat der bundestag der wo er auch
lange gesagt wurde ist zu wenig
beteiligt jetzt ist er dabei jetzt
können sie wenn sie ihren ihren
wahlkreis fahren kann sie sagen ich habe
dem zugestimmt die bundesregierung ist
stärker eingebunden als die länder macht
das jetzt dann ist das einfach
ich denke wir haben das ja gerade gehört
als in der mpk hat man hat man in der
durch die moderation der kanzlerin
ordentliche beschlüsse gefasst die auch
zu erklären waren und am anderen morgen
haben die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten das sehr individuell
umgesetzt bis gar nicht umgesetzt also
das ist ein problem
deshalb haben wir jetzt diese
bundesregelung und das ist ja nicht die
maximal regelung sondern das ist das
mindestmaß also auf dieser ebene ja auch
strengere maßnahmen sind frei in ihren
entscheidungen und wie gesagt die
ausgangssperre ist bei uns jetzt
geregelt 22 oder 24 uhr in rheinland
pfalz mit der fdp gilt sie mit 121 oder
auch wieder schwierig das wird ja
vielleicht jetzt angepasst
aber auch zu der frage
man muss abwägen den wert sozusagen von
gesundheit und leben und den wert einer
vorübergehenden einschränkung von
freiheiten und da denke ich ist es im
moment das übergewicht bei gesundheit
und leben und deshalb glaube ich auch
also alle verfassungsrechtler die wir
befragt haben die sagen das ist alles in
ordnung das ist sozusagen vertretbar und
gegen die länder regelungen mit
ausgangssperren hat ja bisher nach
meinem kenntnisstand auch keiner geklagt
und die gerichte die gefragt worden sind
die haben das also bestätigt also
deshalb glaube ich auch in mannheim
wurde die klage annehmen aber nicht
gegen die länder regelungen sondern
gegen einzelne regelungen vielleicht im
regionalen bereich aber unabhängig davon
wichtig ist dass jetzt durch diese
bundes bremse eine ein mindest standard
da ist auf denen man aufbauen kann
ich bin der felsenfesten überzeugung
dass also dass ein vorübergehender
eingriff ist und grundsätzlich glaube
ich müssen wir nach der pandemie
diskutieren auswerten was ist gut
gelaufen weil sie schlecht gelaufen und
das ja aber das kann schneller kommen
als wichtiger jetzt nochmal zu kommen
wie man es jetzt hinkriegen
wichtig ist glaube ich zu überprüfen ob
also in krisenzeiten wie diesen
der föderalismus so wie er in der
vergangenheit ausgeprägt ist die
richtige lösung ist oder ob wir regeln
brauchen die sozusagen eine einheitliche
steuerung eine schnelle bis jetzt sind
wir es auch nochmal ansprechen da ist
der punkt den ja nun viele so viele
betrifft und der so vielen kummer macht
sind die schulen und die frage wie es
den kindern geht in dieser pandemie da
würde ich gerne mal drauf drauf kommen
weil das ist doch ein wichtiger punkt
den man am anfang wahrscheinlich etwas
unterschätzt man wenn
wo sehen sie im moment diejenigen wo sie
sagen oder besten interessen wurde
eigentlich am meisten berücksichtigt in
dieser pandemie und wissen vielleicht am
wenigsten ich klinke das kann man jetzt
so pauschal an ich nicht an verantworten
denn die dynamik dieser pandemie war ja
sehr unterschiedlich ausgeprägt
gerade am anfang der pandemie eigentlich
bis zum bis zum jahreswechsel man ja vor
allem willen arabien gruppen besonders
schwer betroffen war die ältere
generation in pflege und altenheimen
das war ich ziemlich de solar die
menschen waren sehr einsam waren
eingesperrt oder gar schwer krank auf
der intensivstation sind auch verstorben
dann kam die phase wo jetzt mittlere
alter betroffen war mit infektionen und
jetzt erkennen wir auch dass auch kinder
mehr betroffen sind das macht die ganze
situation sicherlich nicht einfacher
aber umso wichtiger da ist auch das ist
versäumt vom neben der
kommunikationsstrategie ist auch
versäumt vom revier die schule in
widerstandsfähiger machen für diese
pandemie wie können der wechsel
unterricht gewährleisten das ist auch
pädagogisch wertvoller unterricht
stattfindet wie können wir dafür sorge
tragen dass die eltern nicht in
überforderungssituation kommen durch
homeschooling inklusive mit homeoffice
zusammen all diese probleme sind ja
meines erachtens unzureichend adressiert
worden
werden wir jetzt besser durch das neue
gesetz ich glaube ich dass sie viel
besser werden wir haben ja die situation
ist das wechsel unterrichtet und distanz
unterrichts mit meinen augen nach wie
vor willkürlich gewählten zahlen
und hinzu kommt noch dass man über die
digitalisierung in den schulen bauen
erst gar nicht zu sprechen
die unzureichend das ja das wollte ich
eigentlich eine jener strategien all das
gehört ja dazu aber das finden sie
positiv die tests strategien ist fertig
die alleine reicht nicht aus ist zur
teststrecke gehört auch die hygiene
hygiene regeln die müssen auch natürlich
auch durchgeführt werden oder sie haben
auch kinder
ich würde ja gerne mal ein praxisbericht
beisteuern da ist fünf sohnes 7 und die
wahrheit ist natürlich es gibt
engagierte lehrer es gibt engagierte
schulen will ich alles nicht in abrede
stellen
aber am ende bleibt als fazit das ist
ein verlorenes jahr für eine ganze
generation und das liegt natürlich daran
dass wir damals im sommer die völlig
nachvollziehbaren entscheidungen
gegen auch eines kompletten lockt bei
uns in den schulen in der ersten
pandemie wo wir noch sehr wenig wussten
wie man sich verhalten sollen das haben
wir alles akzeptiert die eltern genau
wie die lehrer aber dann irgendwann
musste doch klar sein dass wir
monatelang jetzt zeit haben über den
sommer um dann aber auch einen plan zu
entwickeln sollte es eine zweite oder
dritte welle geben und jetzt sind wir
ein jahr danach und die schulen wissen
doch in wahrheit immer noch nicht
wirklich wie geht diese tests strategie
mein sohn soll sich zu hause testen
lassen mit einem test den wir bekommen
wird gar nicht nach gehaltener karriere
den kann ich auch hinschicken zur schule
und sagen ja der ist der ist negativ
dass das wird alles noch keiner wusste
wo am tag danach wie wie diese
beschlüsse umzusetzen sind
der digital unterrichte distanz
unterricht funktioniert ja eben nicht
flächendeckend in diesem land für alle
klassen funktioniert ja einfach nicht
hätte man das alles vorbereitet würden
wir eltern wir würden uns auch gar nicht
aufregen über über meinetwegen in
schnellen harten locker und wenn die
perspektive danach ein flächendeckender
digitaler geplanter unterricht ist
wechsel unterricht in den klassen wenn
die infrastruktur und der wille da wäre
das den eltern zu organisieren dass
danach dann würde man natürlich auch den
lockdown viel viel positiver auch
mitnehmen kommentieren all das ist nicht
passiert und deswegen ist der frust
natürlich am größten bei den eltern für
die für die schulkinder ist das ein
drama was wird einem jahr passiert dann
ganz viele und natürlich auch der
föderalismus seine seiten trägt da seine
schuld insofern dass sie das größte
versäumnis neben dem impfen auch nicht
ändern
eigentlich schon weil beim vorher waren
die länder individuell zuständig und
haben dann wenn das so stimmt und ich
kann das nachvollziehen haben die länder
das was sie an möglichkeiten haben nicht
genutzt weil für bildung sind die länder
zuständig da ist der bund nicht
zuständig und jetzt in dem bundesland
down regelungen haben wir jetzt
mindeststandards gesetzt ob die richtig
sind aber ist ein weiteres in der
wenigen präsenzunterricht oder indes
tanz unterrichtet in der vorherigen
verhandlungen haben die länder überhaupt
keine einheitliche regelung gefunden
geht es aber wenigstens mal eine
orientierung gegeben
frau wirkt denn er will das muss ja auch
umgesetzt werden können ist immerhin
gefühlt
möglich ist dass die regelung jetzt da
es wenn er umgesetzt schauen wir noch
mal ich würde gerne mal einen moment
bleiben bei den bei den kindern und bei
den jugendlichen ist das eine gruppe die
wir einfach zu lange aus den blick
genommen habe und nicht im blick gehabt
haben
und was würden sie den jetzt sagen wie
schafft man das dass die jetzt noch
mitkommen weil die werden ja auch ganz
spät geimpft und die kinder erst mal gar
nicht also das ist wirklich jetzt gerade
auch mit blick auf die nächste zeit
unglaublich wichtig das sind nicht nur
die schulkinder das sind einfach auch
die älteren jugendlichen und vereinfacht
die berufsanfänger studierende
diejenigen die einen job angefangen
haben also das ist die haben alles so
viel verloren und es ist tatsächlich so
dass wir als es einfach darum gegen die
ganz wohlhabenden gruppen zu schützen
und als die die todeszahlen einfach so
sehr hoch waren da war eben besonders
die sehr alte generation menschen im
pflegeheim betroffen aber es zeigt sich
einfach immer mehr je länger das dauert
desto schwieriger wird das für kinder
jugendliche und junge generation
und deswegen ist es wirklich zentral
wichtig erstens das so schnell wie
möglich die impfungen auch für die
kinder und jugendlichen kommen können
die zahlen aus den ersten studien sind
ja sehr ermutigend aber ich glaube da
sollte man wirklich gast geben was die
zulassungen anbelangt damit man da auch
den kindern und jugendlichen schutz
anbieten kann man demnächst nicht vorbei
wenn sie nicht auch bei wenn ich auch
kinder und jugendliche geschützt werden
können das ist das eine und das andere
mit blick auf das was jetzt versäumt
wurde im bildungsbereich
das ist also das steht wirklich ganz
oben auf der to-do-liste aus meiner
sicht für die politik nach zu arbeiten
da braucht's unterstützungsprogramme da
wird die förderprogramme geben da muss
man einfach sozusagen in diesem
heilungsprozess der möglichst bald
anfangen sollte diesem
gesamtgesellschaftlichen gerade für
diese gruppe wirklich ganz ganz viel an
weil die jetzt einfach sehr sehr lange
gelitten haben und noch eine ganze weile
leiden werden bis eben dann die impfung
da sind und weil man ja auch eine
solidarität braucht in der gesellschaft
am anfang gab es sie ja stark auch mit
den variablen gruppen und jetzt ist die
frage wie man die behälter ich ganz viel
die also man hört das wirklich aus
sozusagen anekdotisch im eigenen umfeld
aber auch da gibt es natürlich
befragungs studien dass die die jüngeren
sich wirklich sehr sehr solidarisch
verhalten haben und wir sind ja die mit
den meisten kontakten die sich aber
trotzdem gerade deswegen besonders stark
in ihren kontakten auch beschränkt haben
und da hört man einfach ganz
nachvollziehbarerweise und jetzt müssen
wir auch noch so lange auf die impfung
warten alle sind vor uns daran wann
kommen denn endlich die kinder und
jugendlichen das ist eine völlig
nachvollziehbare frage und ich glaube da
sollten wir als gesellschaften jetzt
einfach auch sagen also die generation
hat wirklich sehr viel mitgemacht das
hat eine weile gebraucht bis man das so
klar gesehen hat weil die ja auch
erstaunlich resilient war und immer noch
ist da müsste man dann auch und
vielleicht überlegen ob man die eben
frei die impfung muss man überhaupt mal
impfungen kriegen die man werfen kann in
der gruppe da wir nur noch fünf minuten
haben ich würde ganz gerne mal auch auf
die proteste kommen heute gab es
demonstrationen hier auch am bundestag
mehrere tausend menschen
die protestiert haben gegen dieses not
gesetz auch politiker der afg waren
dabei die auch gegen das gesetz gestimmt
haben genau wie die fdp
herr ullmann wo wir sagen sie soll man
damit umgehen mit den protesten
zunächst einmal ist demonstrationsrecht
auch unserem land existent das darf man
jetzt nicht in frage stellen egal ob man
das gut heißen mag oder nicht gut heißen
mag
das ist ein bürgerrecht in wir unserem
land haben und gott sei dank auch haben
das muss natürlich aber in einer
pandemie situation die hygieneregeln
eingehalten werden wenn diese nicht
eingehalten werden verstehe ich auch
kein spaß mehr da müssen natürlich
solche demonstrationen grundsätzlich
verboten werden
aber eine demonstration zu verurteilen
finde ich verkehrt diese kraft handel
als unser land mit unserem land dass wir
als demokratisch
haben dass wir durchaus diese
demonstration auch ertragen können und
heroin in wie weit muss man dann auch so
bis heute in der debatte war ja mit der
afg darüber streiten oder ist das ein
punkt wo sie sagen diese art der
demonstration die argumentation der afg
da müssen wir uns vor allem von
abgrenzen
also ich denke es geht der afg nicht um
lösungen sondern nur darum also protest
zu organisieren
gegen gegen auch unsere demokratischen
regeln
deshalb glaube ich das müssen wir
aushalten müssen dagegenhalten mit guten
argumenten aber deshalb glaube ich mit
der perspektive dass wir die impfungen
das im sommer jeder seine impfung
bekommen hat und das ist ja auch jetzt
in dem infektionsschutzgesetz geregelt
dass also es verordnungen geben soll
dass geimpfte mit getesteten
gleichgestellt werden und dann also neue
freiheiten bekommen dass das auch dazu
führen wird die akzeptanz zu steigern
auch die menschen im grunde dafür durch
neue freiheiten zu belohnen was sie
alles ausgehalten haben in den
zurückliegenden wochen und monaten
gleich noch ein punkt zur afd
heute auch ein bundestagswahl nicht so
die fdp die ja gegen dieses gesetz
gestimmt haben auch die linken haben
dagegen gestimmt
die grünen haben sich enthalten im
gegensatz zur art die an alle anderen
parteien änderungsanträge eingebracht
wir haben konstruktive arbeit auch
geleistet und auch entsprechend
änderungsanträge auch abstimmen lassen
und auch im gesundheitsausschuss
diskutiert die afg hat wochen pause
gemacht und sich nicht daran beteiligen
das ist glaube ich die wesentlichen
unterschiede und da würde ich auch
meinen kollegen hier zustimmen
kfd gilt er als protestpartei als eine
konstruktive oppositionspartei aber herr
rütteln mal eine kleine nur eine kleine
anmerkung es geht hier nicht um neue
freiheiten hier ist um eine
grundgesetzlich verbrieften freiheit
die der staat vorübergehend welche daten
man sagen dass unsere sagen wenn ich die
erststimme im vollen umfang die sind
also nicht neue freiheit und warum ein
geimpftes paaren natürlich nicht nach 22
uhr spazieren gehen sollte ist denn eben
natürlich schwierig zu begründen weil
das hier nicht um neue freiheiten geht
und wie hat das ein verfassungsrechtler
in der expertenanhörung gesagt die gibt
es eben schon diese experten und die
waren übrigens mehrheitlich alle gegen
diese ausgabenbeschränkungen hat ihm
gesagt wir sind hier nicht in einer
notstandsgesetzgebung so wichtig der
gesundheitsschutz ist dann muss diese
maßnahme diesem gesundheitsschutz aber
auch wirklich dienen und so lange das
nicht bewiesen ist kann ich einen der
erst recht einem geimpften panik nicht
verbieten vor die tür zu gehen also geht
hier nicht um neue freiheiten dass er
sich jetzt nicht das letzte neu durch
alte jetzt aussehe sicht des ethikrates
ist es richtig wenn geimpfte dann
besondere rechte erhalten und sollte das
schnell passieren da sind ja keine
besonderen rechte werden
freiheitsbeschränkung aufgehoben also da
werde ich ganz ich meinte andere rechte
allein schon vom etat wird größer
je sicherer man weiß dass jemand nicht
mehr ansteckend ist desto weniger kann
man diese freiheitsbeschränkung
aufrechterhalten man muss sich nur
klarmachen wir sind in der dritten welle
und man muss das ja auch umsetzen können
und wir sind eben kein polizeistaat wo
man dann sozusagen die impfpässe anfängt
zu kontrollieren auf der straße also ich
glaube solange es im moment noch so
schlecht aussieht wäre es klug so eine
gleichstellung von getesteten und
geimpften schon vor zu denken und das
aufheben der ganz harten geschichten
ebenfalls wenn das tatsächlich von der
infektiosität her geht aber maßvoll und
vielleicht jetzt nicht nächste woche
doch das werden wir nächste woche
diskutieren aber die entscheidungen
werden dann spaß und
und dann werden wir wieder eine phoenix
runde ganz stimmt zu diesem thema machen
jetzt aber am ende der sendezeit vielen
dank frau birgit vielen dank der brücke
hertel und holman für diese diskussion
die sicherlich nicht die letzte zum
thema groner ist morgen schauen wir aber
mal ins ausland nämlich in die ukraine
der fall navalny wir fragen wie reagiert
der westen auf das was dort passiert in
der ukraine und auch in russland morgen
also um 18 uhr dann schon dann könnte es
nämlich auch dann bei youtube und
twitter sehen und auch bei den podcast
gibt es auch diese phoenix runde können
sie nämlich auch bei spotify als podcast
also schön wenn sie dabei sind bis dann
tschüss